Welcome to Google I/O 2013.
I am Prashant Labhane from
the Google APIs team.
And today we'll be learning
about getting started with
Google APIs in App Engine
using Python.
In Google APIs' team, we try
really hard to make tools so
that your application
development is easier and you
can use the APIs very easily.
In today's session, we'll be
covering about running a
Quickstart application
locally.
We'll deep-dive into the
Quickstart application.
We'll do application development
using an API.
We'll deploy the application
to App Engine.
And at the end, I'll provide
some reference.
But before getting started,
the first question I ask
before writing any application
is to see what is
provided in the APIs.
You can do that without writing
a single line of code
with a tool called
APIs Explorer.
You can go to that tool
at developers.googl
e.com/apis-explorer.
And as you can see, Google
provides a lot of APIs, some
of them very product-specific
like Blogger and Books.
But we also provide a lot of
infrastructure APIs like Cloud
Storage and Compute Engine.
For today's session, I'm going
to be using one of my favorite
APIs, Google+.
But I would encourage you to try
out this exercise with any
API of your liking.
So as you can see, Google+
provides resources like
activities, comments, and people
information in the API.
So there's a method called a
Search in which you can query
anything, and you will get
results for the activities
that are relevant
to that query.
So as you can see here, it
gives a bunch of items--
the title, the URL, which
is basically a
list of activity resources.
What you can also do with the
Google+ API is to get
information about a particular
users list of activities.
And you can do that using
plus.activities.list.
But before we get into that,
we need to authorize the
application to get access
to the user's data.
We do that using OAuth 2.
So I'm going to turn on
OAuth 2 and allow
access for Google+ API.
And this presents me a
user content screen.
During the course of this
session, you'll find the
screen come up again.
What this is trying to do is
trying to authorize the
application Google APIs Explorer
to access user
Prashant Labhane's data
for the Google+ API.
I'm going to give it access.
And then I can use
my user ID here.
For brevity, you can use Me as
the code word for user ID.
And it will pick up the user
from your browser.
And I want to see whatever
I have shared publicly.
Now, as you do that, you will
see, again, the same list of
activities.
But this one is particular to
the activities that are shared
by the user.
Looking at this API, I have a
good sense of what application
I want to build.
So I will be building an
application which displays the
URLs of all the activities
for a particular user.
So we can now get started with
the first section, which is
running your Quickstart
application.
For the purpose of this
exercise, I'm using a brand
new Google account
called Google
I/O 13 Python [? dev ?].
So all the flows you'll be
seeing in today's session will
be first-time session.
If you already have registered
with App Engine or APIs
Console, your flow might look
a little bit different.
So let's get started.
The first thing you need
to do is to register a
Google Cloud Project.
And you can get an instance
of Google Cloud Project at
cloud.google.com.
Since this is the first time
it's going to ask me for a
verification--
and I'm going to go ahead
and complete the
verification flow.
So as you can see in the
previous screen, I had to get
a verification code.
You can get that via a phone
call or a text message.
I just got my verification
code, which
I'm going to verify.
And that brings me into the
Google Cloud Console.
I'm going to agree to the
terms of service.
And I'm going to create
a new Cloud Project.
I'm going to call it Google
APIs Quickstart.
By default, the Cloud Project
comes with a project ID.
But you can also choose
something that you like.
I'll try to see if I can get
something of my liking.
So I'll try Google APIs
Quickstart, which already
exists, so I'm going to say,
Google I/O 13 Quickstart.
And that would be the
name of the project
that we'll be using.
So it's going to create a new
Cloud Project at this point.
While we are doing that, let's
also download the App Engine
SDK, which we'll be using
later in this session.
You can download the
App Engine SDK from
developers.googl
e.com/appengine/download.
You can also find
the link in the
presentation for this video.
I'm using a MacBook.
And it already has
Python installed.
I am going to use Hands,
the App Engine SDK.
In the meantime, the Cloud
Project has been created.
The name of the project is
Google APIs Quickstart.
And the project ID is Goog
I/O 13 Quickstart.
The Google Cloud Project is the
home for a lot of other
Google technologies like Google
Cloud Storage, Cloud
SQL, Bit Query, which I would
encourage you to try after
this session.
Now my Google App Engine
SDK is downloaded.
I am going to extract
the file.
And I am going to move it to
my Applications folder.
When you install the Google App
Engine Launcher, you also
want to make sure--
let me change my system
preferences.
OK.
When you use Google App Engine
Launcher, you also want to
make sure that you create the
right symlinks so that you'll
be able to use the SDK tool
from command line.
So this is what it does the
first time it starts up.
If you happen to miss the step,
you can always go back
to Google App Engine Launcher
to make symlinks, and it'll
create the links for you.
OK.
Now we can get started
with the next step.
Google provides a set of client
libraries to make it
easy for you to use APIs, though
most of the APIs are
resource-oriented and you can
always write your libraries
around the protocol.
And we encourage people to use
the client libraries, because
they are easier to use and they
also encompass a lot of
functions that you will see.
You can access the client
libraries at developers.googl
e.com/api-client-library.
As you can see, Google provides
libraries in very
many languages.
For today's session, we'll
be using Python.
Google Client libraries make it
very easy to take care of a
lot of your application tasks
like authentication batching,
logging, et cetera, so that you
can focus more on writing
the code for the API, as you
will see in the next sections.
What we also provide, in
addition to the client
library, is a way to get you
started quickly on your
project with the Quickstart
widget.
So in this case, as we
discussed, I'm going to be
using the Google+ API.
I'm going to be deploying
it on Google App Engine.
And I'm going to configure
my Cloud
Project with this project.
So as you see, it's already
pre-populated with Google APIs
Quickstart, which is the Cloud
Project we just created.
Please make sure you read
the terms of service.
This one is the terms of service
for the Google+ API.
And it's going to finish
the widget.
What you get at the end of
Quickstart is your starter
application as well as the
client credentials
that go with it.
So I'm going to download
both of these.
And as you can see, in my
Downloads folder I have the
Client Secrets file as well
as the App Engine Project.
So let's take a look at the
App Engine Project.
The App Engine Project comes
with a default Client Secrets.
And if you take a closer
look, the Client
Secrets file is empty.
It doesn't have the client
ID or the Client Secret.
What you could do is, from the
developer's console, paste in
the client ID and the
Client Secret.
But the method I prefer to use
is to just drop the file into
the folder.
And now, to make it easy for
this session, I'm going to
rename this folder to be called
My App Engine Project
so that we can refer
to it more easily.
OK.
Now that I have the new Client
Secrets into the folder, let's
go to the next step, which
is to run this Quickstart
application locally.
As you can see, we have
downloaded the App Engine SDK
and we have created symlinks.
And the App Engine SDK comes
with a lot of handy tools to
run application.
One of them is called the
Absorber that lets you run an
App Engine application locally
on your machine.
So I'm going to go to the
Downloads folder, and it has
my App Engine Project.
I am going to run dev
app server against
my App Engine Project.
And it's going to start up a
server that you can access on
local host 8080.
So this is your application
running locally.
The first screen that you see
here is asking for the user
authentication to
the application.
Since this is a locally-running
application,
it does not require
any log-in.
So it's a test log-in screen.
The next screen that you see
is the OAuth screen that we
previously saw.
But in this case, the service
account for the project is
asking to authorize that
application to get the data
for Prashant Labhane
for Google+ APIs.
I'm going to say, Accept.
And it's going to
take a while.
And with that, we have a
locally-running application.
As you can see, the application
doesn't do much
but render HTML.
It gives you handy links
on how to use the
Google+ API in Python.
With that, we have our
application running locally.
Let's move to the next section,
where we'll do a
deep-dive of the Quickstart
application
code, what it does.
And we'll do a bit of
application development later.
So let's get into the deep-dive
of the code.
As you can see, the
project is here.
You can use an ID of any choice
to import this project.
In my case, I'm going to just
use my text editor.
So the main file that controls
your application in the
Quickstart project is main.pi.
And let's do a code walk-through
of what that
application does.
The first thing you would notice
that it imports the
Client Secrets file that we
put in the same folder.
It's creating a service
for your API.
And this is the service that
you can use to invoke
resources and methods upon.
It creates an OAuth-decorated
blazed on the
Client Secret file.
And it has a main handler and
Get method, which is decorated
with OAuth Required.
The decoration OAuth Required
makes sure that the OAuth flow
is called before the Get
method is called.
Since this is a simple
application, we will be using
OAuth Required.
However, when you're developing
your complex
application, you want to make
sure that the content screen
shows up at the right time, in
which case I would encourage
you to try OAuth Aware, which
lets the application take
control of when the
OAuth credential
gets checked and called.
And as you can see, the
application is writing out a
simple HTML.
What you will also notice is
the application is a WSGI
application, which comes
with Main Handler.
But it also comes with the OAuth
2 callback handlers,
which take care of OAuth flow
on behalf of you in the
application.
You can also register other
handlers as and when needed
for this WSGI application.
Now that we have a good sense of
what the Quickstart code is
doing, we can now get started
with coding our application.
So I already walked you through
the OAuth flow.
And we did a code
walk-through.
Let's get to the next section,
which is application
development.
What you can see is the
locally-running application
gives you a handy link to
the Python Google+ API.
So let's take a look.
As you can see, the same
resources that we saw at the
start of this session for APIs
Explorer are now exposed as
Python methods that can
be called upon.
So let's take a look
at Activities.
And you can see the same methods
like Search and List
can be called upon
in this API.
So let's go ahead and
write some code.
So what I'm going to do is I
mirrored the same activities
that we did earlier with the
APIs Explorer in Python code.
So I'm going to get Activities
results.
I'm going to do it using
the service.
And as you can see, the service
is created here for
the Google+ API.
If you're using a different API,
then you can invoke the
methods relevant to that API.
So I'm going to call
service.activities.
And as you can see,
the Activities
has a search method.
So I'm going to call Search
using the query, Google.
And now I'm going to execute
this command.
Another thing to notice is for
executing any API call, you
need to make sure you get an
authenticated HTTP object to
carry that API call over.
So in this case, it's
already decorated.
I'm going to use the HTTP object
from the Decorator.
So it's going to be
decorator.http, which is the
authenticated HTTP connection.
And the next thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to write
out Activities Result
in the HTML.
And remove all this code.
OK.
And now I'll make sure
I save the file,
because that's important.
One of the good things about
developing with dev app server
is it automatically takes care
of any code changes you make.
So you don't have to go and
kill your application and
restart it.
But you can keep you dev app
server running, keep
developing.
And you will be able to see the
changes without having to
restart dev app server.
So in this case, as you can see,
I modified my code and
it's giving me a list of Python
objects relevant to the
query, Google.
What I'm also going to do next
is to get a list of activities
for my user account.
As you can recall, in APIs
Explorer we had to
turn on OAuth 2.
But this application is already
decorated with OAuth 2
Required, which means you can
call the List method for the
Activities in my account, and
the Decorator OAuth 2 Required
will take care of running
OAuth 2 on your behalf.
So I'm going to use List.
User ID equals Me, and
Collection is public.
And I'm going to execute it the
same way I executed the
Search, using the Decorator's
authenticated HTTP object.
If you ever find yourself not
knowing what the parameters
are, you can always go to the
documentation for the API and
check out what the query
parameters are.
Now, again, as I said earlier,
when you change your code,
just make sure you save your
file, and you'll be able to
see the changes quickly.
So this is the list of
activities that is shared by
my user account.
What you can also do in App
Engine Python is to use
templates to render the
HTML in a nice way.
As I said earlier, we'll be
creating links for the various
sets of activities.
The Quickstart application comes
with a built-in template
that you can use to
render these.
In Python 2.5, it does
Django templates.
But if you are using Python
2.7, that would be
[? Django. ?]
So let's write a small
template file
to render the results.
So let's create an HTML file.
And I'm going to write
a Django template.
And I know that I'm going to
be getting items in this
object, as you have seen
in the APIs Explorer.
And also, you can inspect this
code, which tells you that
it's a list of items and each
of the items has a URL and a
title, which is relevant
to the activities.
So this is what my template
is going to do.
So I'm going to get the
link from Items URL.
And I'm going to be getting
the item's title.
And I'm going to put
some line breaks.
And that is a very simple
template that I'm going to be
calling activities.html.
And now that I have the
template, I can go to my code.
And I'm going to invoke the
template and render my
Activities result object
using this template.
So I'm first going to declare
the template path.
And as you can see, the
activities.html file is in the
same folder, so I'm going to be
using the directory name.
And joining with
activities.html.
And next up, I'm going to be
rendering the template path,
which is the template that
it just wrote with
the Activities result.
If you are wondering where the
template model came from, you
can see, as I told earlier,
the Quickstart application
comes with the default
template.
And with that, I'm going
to save my file.
And as you can see, it now
renders a link to the
activities that are shared
by my user account.
And if you click on them, you
will go to the specific
activity post that
is relevant.
Now, with that, I am pretty
happy with my application.
And I want to deploy
it to App Engine.
So we can get started with the
next section, which is deploy
to App Engine.
Before we do that, let's
understand a little bit about
client credentials.
The client credential file,
which I downloaded earlier,
client_secrets.json, was to run
the application locally.
To deploy the application on App
Engine, we need to get the
credentials for a web
application on App Engine.
You can do that by visiting
developers.google.com/console.
And go to API access.
And just create a
new client ID.
In this case, it's a
web application.
The site name is your Cloud
Project ID name.
And that is also the name of
your App Engine application.
And it will be hosted
on appspot.com.
So your site name would be
Goog I/O 13 Quickstart.
I'm going to go to my Cloud
Project and check it again.
It's Goog I/O 13 Quickstart.
So the application
name is correct.
And it's going to be hosted
on appspot.com.
And like that, you create
a new client credential.
What you also want to do is
once you've created this
client credential, you want to
make sure that the application
still continues to
run locally.
To do that, you can edit your
settings and add Local Host to
the redirect URIs, which make
sure that the application
continues to run locally.
However, when you are finally
deploying your application, I
would recommend moving this
out so that it's safer.
What I'm going to do, now that
I have created a client
credential, I'm going
to download the
Client Secrets JSON.
And as you can see here,
I have a new
Client Secrets file.
So I'm going to remove the old
one and move the new Client
Secrets into the project.
The second thing that you want
to do is to configure your
application on how the code
is deployed to App Engine.
In Python, that's controlled
by a file called ab.yamal,
which comes in your Quickstart
project.
You want to enter your
application ID, which is Goog
I/O 13 Quickstart in our case.
What you also want to do is I
prefer to be secure and always
use HTTPS for my applications.
And you can do that using the
parameter Secure Always.
If your Quickstart application
code doesn't come with Secure
Always, I would recommend
you adding this.
And I'm going to
save this file.
And now we are ready
to deploy this
application to App Engine.
As I said earlier, I'm going to
stop my local application.
The App Engine SDK comes with
a variety of handy tools.
One such tool is AppConfig,
which lets you upload your
application to App Engine.
So I'm going to update, and
I'm going to give it the
location of my App
Engine project.
And the first time it runs, it's
going to ask you about
the account with which you have
your Cloud Projects and
things like that.
So I'm just going to
enter my password.
And with that, this
is the first run.
It's going to take some time to
deploy the application that
I just wrote locally
into App Engine.
And it seems like
it's completed.
So I'm going to go to
my browser and go to
googio13quickstart.appspot.com.
And it's going to ask
me to log in.
So this is the part where the
user is authenticating to the
App Engine application.
This is the second screen, which
is the OAuth screen.
Now, as you can see, this
is showing up again.
This is because this time the
application is different.
In the previous case, you were
running your application
locally, and that's the
application you authorized.
Now that you have deployed it
to App Engine, you want to
authorize the App Engine
application and the
authorization to access the
data for Prashant Labhane.
I'm going to go and
accept that.
And with that, you have the same
application that you just
developed locally and deployed
onto App Engine.
Now, with that, we come to
the end of this session.
But I wanted to give you some
handy references and things
that are happening
in Google APIs.
If you are more interested, I
would definitely recommend you
to check out Google Cloud
Endpoints, which enables third
parties to host APIs
on Google.
Now, this is a very
powerful concept.
And we are trying to bring
the client libraries and
authentication and all the good
stuff that you just saw
in this session to third-party
APIs as well, so that as an
application developer, you can
use Google APIs as well as you
can use third-party APIs to
create really powerful
applications on App Engine.
If you are interested in the
Java version of this talk, I
would recommend you watching
[INAUDIBLE]
on getting started with Google
APIs in Java on App Engine.
And I would also recommend you
to going to some of the
reference, more specifically
developers.google.com and
cloud.google.com to check out
all the different technologies
that are offered in
Google Cloud.
With that, we come to the
end of this session.
Thanks for watching, and have
a good time coding.